This is the world's number one youngest
quant trader to achieve over 1.5 million
dollars in payouts in less than 18
months placing over 30 trades per day.
>> Prop firms are a generational wealth
builder. So, I knew I needed a prop firm
specific [music] approach. And when I
was modeling level two order flow with
specific take profit stop loss, I found
that my returns were not going to be
incredibly high. The reason for that is
[music] the prop firms don't want you to
make money. So, they obviously have to
structure their rules in a way where the
most common trading approaches is not
going to work. So, you have to do
something against the norm if you want
to stand out and be extremely profitable
on prop firms.
>> Introducing JJ Simon, a quantitative
finance graduate who didn't approach
prop firms like everyone else. He
instead found a mathematical loophole
that is completely mechanical, removes
all psychology, and turns him into a
payout machine. In this episode, JJ
reveals why he treats the evaluation and
funded phase completely differently, the
exact maths he runs before buying a
single evaluation, and how taking 30
plus trades a day made going until
almost impossible.
>> Well, what's your thoughts on patterns?
To see a signature of price to say,
"Okay, we're breaking down."
>> I don't believe in it too much. I think
most of it is artificial.
>> What does artificial mean?
>> Like institutions placing huge fake
[music] candles that should not be read
as like true price action.
>> Why would they exist?
>> There's a few different ways to approach
this question. Uh so,
instead of back testing like you're on a
live account, back test like you're on a
prop firm challenge. See how many times
you hit the max drawdown. See how many
times you hit the profit target. And
then when you get to the funded account,
you need to change pretty much
everything because the evaluation and
the funded account, you have to optimize
for different things. The evaluation,
you have to optimize for your chance of
hitting the profit target before hitting
the max loss. And then on funded
account, you need to optimize for your
expected [music] value, which is
basically like your chance of a payout
multiplied by how large that payout is.
Personally, I trade different strategies
on eval and funded just because they're
like incredibly different.
>> I'm very curious to know the process of
scaling because if we're sitting at 1.5
million, it means you saw multiple six
figures on evaluations. The first
question that someone in the comments
will have is, "Where did you get this
hundreds of thousands of dollars from?"
But, probably is you reinvested payouts.
So, I going to build a journey from 100
to 1,000, from 1,000 to 10, from 10 to
100, and from 100 to a million.
>> Um the first one, I was thankful to
[music] start with.
>> Hey Dyson, before we jump into today's
episode, I want to extend an invite to
you to our Titans of Tomorrow Inner
Circle. So, as we have the episode today
with JJ, something that he's developed
is the prop firm math loophole, applying
his quantitative finance lens to the
prop firm rules. So, what we create with
him off camera is the exact formulas he
used so that you don't need to learn all
the math. You can actually have the
drag-and-drop, plug-and-play formulas
he's used to get the most out of prop
firms. That's going to be one thing of
many inside of the Titans of Tomorrow
Inner Circle. Which means every single
week you're going to get playbooks and
newsletters from not only today's guest,
but every guest in the past and every
guest upcoming, automatically sent to
your inbox. And as the name suggests,
it's an inner circle, which means you
get to tell me exactly the questions you
want answered based on the upcoming
guest roster that we have. And most
importantly, as we travel the world,
every tour we do is multi-country or at
least a dozen states. That means every
time we're in your city, we're going to
alert you to have an in-person meetup.
That means we go for a dinner together
and talk all about charts, trading, and
the guest, or even better for some of
you, invited to join us behind the
scenes on the shoots to even meet the
guest that we are interviewing. So,
click the link below to join the Titans
of Tomorrow Inner Circle. And without
further ado, let's get into today's
episode with JJ. What was it from your
degree, which areas from your degree um
were specifically relevant? And I guess
the goal for this conversation is to
help unpack the relevant things and your
experiences and successes and convert it
to someone that doesn't have the degree
that you do.
>> Yeah, I think the most important things
is math and math and statistics, just
because with prop firm trading, they
obviously have the rules and everything,
and you need to model your returns based
on the separate rules that they have on
different firms and the different
challenges and funded accounts and all
that stuff. So, I really was able to use
that very strong background in math and
stats in order to create positive
expected value in all of my trades based
on my win rate, based on my risk reward,
everything I knew like exactly which
prop firm challenge to trade on, exactly
how much to risk, exactly how much to go
for in terms of profit target every
single trade just because I was able to
optimize around the specific rule set
that they gave me.
>> Oh, interesting. So, your goal was not
actually find an edge in the market and
then take that edge to the prop firm. It
was rather have an edge or have an
approach, but really have the edge in
the prop firm arena.
>> Yeah, 100%. I I have a strategy that it
works on live, but it's not going to be
insane returns on live. It's going to be
very small positive expected value.
That's because it has an asymmetric risk
reward.
>> In that case, can we unpack how we build
an edge around prop firms? What are the
Let's start with what are the variables
to consider? And then I guess we have
the rules as another layer of the prop
firms. And then the decision factor of
okay, should I or should I not? So,
let's build the foundation. Where do you
begin when you're trying to build a prop
firm model?
>> Yeah, most important thing obviously is
your win rate and risk reward. So, if
you're trading one specific strategy,
obviously you need to know the risk
reward, you need to know your win rate.
And then based on that, there must exist
an optimal prop firm for you to trade on
just because they all have different
rules. So, if you're to simulate it
across all of the different prop firms
with your exact strategy, your exact
stats, then one of those rule sets must
fit your strategy the best. Just plainly
speaking. So, I think people should try
and figure out which prop firm rules
would fit them best. And that would
honestly just be through back testing.
So, instead of back testing like you're
on a live account, just finding your
equity curve over time, back test like
you're on a prop firm challenge. See how
many times you hit the max drawdown. See
how many times you hit the profit
target. And then when you get to the
funded account, you need to change
pretty much everything because the
evaluation and the funded account, you
have to optimize for different things.
The evaluation, you have to optimize for
your chance of hitting the profit target
before hitting the max loss.
And then on funded account, you need to
optimize for your expected value, which
is basically like your chance of a
payout multiplied by how large that
payout is.
So, it's two different things. You could
even change your risk reward or change
your strategy because personally I trade
different strategies on Eval and Funded
just because they're like incredibly
different.
>> Well, let's start off with the Eval. So,
we have the moving parts of risk reward,
win rate, trade frequency. Is that
important to you?
>> Not really. There is an optimal way to
do it, but it is not for me.
>> Okay. So, actually only starting off
with these two variables,
what about risk per trade? Would that be
standardized?
>> Yeah, you should definitely have a
static risk per trade.
>> Okay. And your risk reward or your
profit target is always fixed.
>> It is for evaluation. It's fixed.
>> And and you will not allow runners or
partials along the way.
>> No.
>> What is the reason for this?
>> Leaving runners and partials is probably
one of the worst things you can do on
prop firms.
The reason is obviously consistency rule
just in general on most evaluations, you
can't make the whole thing in one day.
If you could, then it's probably better
to leave those runners.
But mainly with the trailing drawdown, I
don't like to leave runners or [snorts]
close my position early or
anything like that, because of how the
trailing drawdown moves. The just since
the trailing drawdown moves up at the
end of the day on the futures accounts,
then you can obviously you obviously
need to build a strategy around that.
Basically, like I'm solving for max
drawdown in my equity curve.
>> Okay. And therefore, are you are you
thinking drawdown versus profit target
as the formula or are you thinking total
evaluation fees versus total payouts?
And then it's just like a slot machine,
you keep rolling the dice and you allow
the math to play out.
>> Yeah, it's definitely the second one.
I look to go for like a 3x return on my
evaluation spend. And then when I do
well, I get four, five, six times. If I
do worse, then I'm going to get like
2.7. Like the downside is extremely
capped with prop firms. That's why I do
it instead of a live account. But what
people should do on the evaluation
specifically is realize if you have a
$3,000 profit target and a $2,000 max
loss, that is a 1 to 1.5. So, if you
automatically change your risk reward to
a 1 to 1.5, then you're just going to
pass more challenges because of how the
trailing drawdown works.
>> Hey Titans, let's take a quick break
from the episode to talk about a sponsor
and partner of the show, that is Olap
Prime. Now, a lot of traders have been
talking about Olap Prime because they
were recently the winner of the fastest
payout prop firm award in the IFX Expo
here in Dubai. And something that you
don't see so often is that they are
backed by their own brokerage firm, Olap
Prime Markets. And a few things that I
love about Olap Prime is that they have
offers for futures, forex, and crypto
traders. Most importantly, they allow
you to trade on over eight platforms.
And further, they do a 95% profit split.
unheard of, which means whatever you
make, you keep 95% of it. And most
importantly, because of their award,
they're one of the only prop firms that
offer a 1-hour payout through a
structured 10.1-hour payout system. Your
payouts are practically on demand, which
means you can spend more time on the
charts trading, withdraw your profits,
and go back to the markets. With all
these steps, measures, and awards in
place, they're truly redefining
transparency and trust in the prop firm
space. So, if you want to work with a
prop firm that you can trust and a
partner of the show, click the link in
the description or use the code TOT for
Titans of Tomorrow to get the best
prices and discounts that I've
personally negotiated for you guys, our
Titans of Tomorrow audience. With that
being said, let's get back into today's
episode. Why why would someone not try
and achieve a 1:10? Why would like is it
just something that is the math doesn't
play out or it screws things against you
even though it seems like it's in your
favor? Why not go for the highest
asymmetrical gain as possible?
>> Technically, if if their 1:10 was the
exact same profitability in terms of
like expectancy, expected value, my
1:1.5
it's going to take them with the
consistency rule and then if they lose
like 100, win 1,000, realistically, it's
going to take them probably 20 trades to
eventually hit that because they're
going to go up 1,000 minus minus minus
up 1,000 minus minus minus.
They'll be slightly positive in the long
run if they have a good strategy, but
it's going to take them forever to hit
that plus 3,000 or they're going to need
three in a row, which with 1:10 is like
extremely unlikely. So, it would take
them
I'm just going to guess like a week to a
month to to pass the eval. Whereas I'm
doing it I'm passing like 10 evals in a
day.
Just by taking so many trades of smaller
risk to reward.
>> How often are you placing a trade?
>> I trade about 20 different times per
day.
>> 20 trades per day. Are they unique
positions or copy traded?
>> Unique positions. I try not to copy
trade. I'll layer trades in like if
one's in profit, like a funded account's
in profit, I'll layer in evals in the
same direction.
>> This seems pretty intense. What's what's
the methodology behind that?
>> I honestly just like speed. Uh with prop
firms I try to trade all of my accounts
every single day. Um I've constantly
been reminding myself that if I take 20
trades per day
it's the exact same as someone who takes
one trade a day for a month.
And if I'm able to trade 20 times as
much with the same edge, I'm going to
make 20 times as much in terms of my
profit.
>> Got it. Assumes a few things. Number one
is psychological decay.
Number two assumes that
uh you can get the same expectancy or
more importantly the same promises of
win rate, risk reward, etc. With a
higher trade frequency. And I wonder
would it not diminish would it would
alpha diminish the more you the more
often you seek it?
>> Um personally no, because in my
experience with prop firms,
um I'm just using a bias. So I have a
high time frame bias of where the price
is going to charge in for the next 30
minutes to an hour. So I guess it's not
too high time frame, but I look forward
30 minutes to an hour, which direction
um do I think it's going to go?
And then
>> Just using market structure?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Reversion. We'll get into that later
probably. And then I'll just take
consecutive trades in a row. So instead
of doing like one eval all the way for
one trade, I'll size up. I'll do one
eval here, another, another, another. So
I'm getting like five evaluations in the
same direction as taking one trade like
someone would do on a live account.
>> I didn't follow. So if if if I'm buying
at the open let's say and it's on eval
account number one, the moment that
one's in a little bit of profit, then I
re-enter on the second account as
opposed to one or take the first entry
on all accounts.
>> I just don't like copy trading
personally. It's really bad for my
psychology. Might be for others as well.
I find if I trade every single account
individually, I'm taking 20 trades per
day. On average, I'm going to win like
98% of my days just because I have 20
trades of a sample size. Like people can
get a winning month if they take one
trade a day cuz that's 20 trades. So, if
I take 20 trades in one day, then I'm
going to have a winning day just because
I had 20 trades with a slight positive
expectancy.
>> I got it. You squeeze someone's average
month a couple months compressed into a
singular day. What is your
win rate even if you end the day green?
What is your Yeah, what's your win rate
during the day?
>> Win rate changes a lot with my strategy.
There's a few different ways to approach
this question.
So, risk reward is obviously the most
important one on prop firms. I'll do the
one to 1.5 on most of my evaluations.
Some of them I'll do one to two. Some of
them I'll do one to one. So, I have a
ton of different risk rewards based on
what the market shows me. And then
funded accounts, some I'll do one to
one. Some I'll do one to 1.5, one to
four, whatever. So, I have a a ton of
different risk rewards. I cycle through
all of them. And then if I see a one to
1.5 in the market, I know I'm going to
choose this account because a one to 1.5
is best for this account specifically.
>> Okay, so I'm going to read between the
lines. You tell me if if I'm on the
right track because you mentioned mean
reversion which is throwing me off. So,
I want to I want to get into it. You
identify a intraday trend. For this, I
would assume you use 15-minute or
30-minute market structure.
>> 1 minute.
>> 1-minute market structure to find a
trend for the next 30 minutes.
Okay.
Let's say we're in a bullish scenario.
Bullish scenario from the 1-minute time
frame only or are you using higher time
frames to establish a trend?
>> Just 1 minute and I'll look back 6 hours
if needed for a really high time frame
bias, but mostly I'm just looking 1
minute. Market opens, it goes this way,
I'm just going to trade back to the
open.
>> If if I was looking at a 1-minute trend
and my look back was a couple of hours,
there's so much so much variance in what
that could mean because I could be
inside of a daily point of interest. So,
even though I was looking bullish, I'm
consuming a bearish POI, and then I'm
waiting for a rejection. That could be
one lens, even though it looks the same.
Another optically similar scenario would
be I'm in no-man's land. I'm just
approaching a POI. Another one is I've
just broken structure. I'm free-falling.
So, there's so many things that would
look optically the same on M1, but you
zoom out a bit, it'll be totally
different. How do you factor in for
that?
>> I mean, that's all all a very great
point if you are on a live account.
Since I'm trading on a prop firm, all I
need is a slight edge in a bias in my
favor. So, I don't care if it's no-man's
land. I don't care if it's near
something point of interest or whatever.
All I'm trading is a specific direction.
I have a direction based on what I think
the fair price of the futures are, and
I'll just trade all of my accounts in
that direction every time I see an
entry.
>> I I see the point. You're not looking
for a whole move. You're not looking for
a trend. You're looking for a probable
pocket. And that probable pocket is just
I need to be accurate for whatever price
is going to be in 30 minutes. And
therefore,
I I with a 1:2 up to 1:2 risk to reward,
that means your stop loss size is just
basically a session low, and you're
targeting the average session
volatility. That's basically the window
of that you play.
>> Approximately, yes. I do take static
risk and static profit targets. Like
each of my accounts, I know exactly on
this account I'm going to risk 1,000, go
for 2,000. This account I'm going to
risk 1,000, go for 1,500. And then maybe
here risk 500, go for 2,000.
>> Why is there variance on risk per
account?
>> With the prop firm specific approach, uh
just because they have the optimal rule
sets. Like you can just optimize your
exact stop loss and take profit for
those rule sets.
>> Let's get into the the mean reversion
side. Or basically, I'm trying to get
clarity on your approach uh so that I
can visualize it, and the viewers can
also visualize. When you wake up and you
you you're on the session open, and
you're about to place 20, 30 trades for
the day, how do you set up your day? How
do you begin?
>> I'll start at 8:30 a.m. Eastern just
because there's usually news there. I'll
just get my first trade in just a
continuation of the news because I'm
betting that news most of the time is
going to be priced in pretty fairly. So
that when news comes out there's a huge
candle, I'll just trade a continuation
of that candle for my first trade of the
day.
And then after that I'll take usually
like three to four trades trying to
revert that move. So if news came out it
was very very bullish, then I would
trade multiple times probably three or
four evaluations trying to short back to
the pre-news price because I believe on
average the news was forecasted and
priced incorrectly. So the increased
volatility solely from the fact the news
actually was released should not impact
the fair price of the futures.
>> You mentioned to me off camera that
quants or or people in your field don't
really believe in chart patterns. So I
want to extend that out in terms of what
the
what is the correct lens from your
perspective to look at price? What is
the best way to visualize and understand
what price is?
>> Honestly, I think it's just use news
because we're trading futures of I mean
personally I'm trading futures of of
Nasdaq. So I look at the index and index
made up of stocks and usually the things
that are going to change fair price of
stocks is news.
Basically like forecasting what's going
to happen in the future because of a
news release. So I try to use a lot of
macroeconomic factors like that into a
very very small intraday
in order to gain a small bias. And then
a small bias is like extremely
profitable on prop firms if you have
good risk management.
>> Does it only mean you trade Sorry, does
it mean you only trade news days?
>> I trade every day as well just because I
have the same theory as news as I do
with session opens. Whenever the session
opens obviously increase in volatility.
Sometimes or most of the time at least
in my opinion it creates an unfair move.
So just because volume came into the
market and it moved a specific
direction, that shouldn't change the
fair underlying price of the stocks that
I'm technically trading when I'm doing
Nasdaq futures.
>> When you say fair value of price,
it's a relative term. So
fair relative to what and over what
duration? So are you looking at fair
price as an absolute criteria on a
day-by-day basis and then you're using
that as a we're overextended or
overbought, oversold on a daily basis or
would you do this on an hourly per
session? What is What is the reference
point?
>> I do it every day. First, fair price
that I will assume is just 9:29 Eastern
before the market opens. And then from
there, if there's consolidation and then
more breakouts, I'll just read the most
recent consolidation as a fair price.
>> So, you you you establish the fair price
as so and then as we break out, you look
for one buy opportunity when you see
that move is exhausted or depleted, then
you look for the sell back to the fair
price
and vice versa if it goes the other way.
Uh-huh. So, I'm still trying to figure
out how would you squeeze 20-30 trades
into a
a single day period?
>> Yeah, so 8:30 a.m. gives me the
continuation of news and then usually
three reversions or so on that. New York
a.m., one continuation, three or four
reversions. And then from there, I'll
take a longer trade. Usually going into
lunch hour like 11:00 a.m., I'll enter
one final trade and it's a much longer
trade just cuz I'm trying to play it out
from 11:00 all the way until 2:00. At
2:00 p.m., New York p.m. session opens.
I'll start again one continuation, three
to four reversions. 6:00 p.m. session,
same thing. One continuation, three to
four reversions. And then again, one
more time Asian session at 8:00 p.m.
>> Oh, you're trading all the whole day.
Okay, so this means
I'm guessing the most important thing
for you is not higher time frame, is not
trend, is not points of interest. What
is most important is reaction of M1
related to markers in time throughout
the day. So, would you believe there is
a roadmap or a daily cycle that is
something repeating and predictable?
>> Not from session to session, but within
a session, I do believe there are unfair
moves and if you are able to revert
those unfair moves, then you have a
positive expectancy on a live account.
>> So, one common thing that I see online
regarding session mechanics would be you
have a build-up of sorts, you have a or
accumulation, you have a manipulation,
then you have expansion and vice versa
for bearish.
Is that kind of the foundations we're
we're speaking about?
>> I'm personally not too
uh
well knowing of the online lingo, but
um
I'm just not too familiar with it in
general. I don't like I don't know what
those terms mean, but um
I guess it's a better question for you
actually. Do you think my strategy is
like very similar to those things that
you've seen online?
>> I'm trying to understand exactly how
what are the what are the mechanics of
this session because you're breaking
into phases.
>> Right.
>> So, I guess each phase has a purpose and
an objective. And you got to be you got
to be knowing of when is the phase
started? Here's a signal for it. This is
the phase happening. Here's the signal.
And this is phase one completed. Here's
the signal. What are these signals? Are
they just markers in time? Or is it
certain things you see in price?
Basically, say how do you identify and
coordinate phases throughout the
session?
>> Yeah, so I kind of split it up into two
phases. Obviously, the first is the
opening continuation right at 9:30. So,
like the minute any session opens, I'm
ready to take a continuation.
>> So, the priority on the open of fit this
phase one is time. Time is the trigger.
Okay.
>> Yeah, so session opens the first one.
And then when volume starts dying out,
it will usually start to consolidate.
From there, there's obviously that pack
of consolidation. I will trade when it
breaks structure back towards the
opening price as the second phase.
>> Okay. Consolidation being the typical we
got a range of a high and a low. You see
you see almost a box or whatever. And
then you waiting for the break
indicating to you, okay, we're starting
to mean revert. Does Does this need to
happen at a window of time?
>> As long as it's before 11:00 a.m. I
don't care.
>> Okay. Okay, so you got to see an
extended move and then before a certain
time you got to see a a break in price.
Break and then I know what what's your
thoughts on patterns? To see to see a
signature of price to see, okay, we're
breaking down.
>> I don't believe in it too much. I think
most of it is artificial when market
makers are balancing their inventory.
>> What does artificial mean? Is is meant
to confuse?
>> like institutions placing huge bulk
orders like obviously create huge fake
candles that should not be read as like
true price action.
>> Why would they exist?
>> Institutions usually looking to load up
or exit positions in mass and that can
create unfair moves as well.
>> Okay, and would they would they not be
considered almost a digital footprint of
an institutional intent? For example, if
I see a something that I can define as a
institutional signature and it showed me
a bearish signal, then this means okay,
I'm ready to mean revert and therefore
because someone someone has
offloaded or or put on a large position,
here's the signature and therefore if
they've if an institution has bought a
large amount, then price is likely going
to go up. Can use that as a signal to
then act upon?
>> I personally have not investigated using
institutional signals.
I think there's definitely some alpha
behind it because institutions most of
the time are correct since they're
making money,
but personally no, I've not explored it.
>> So what is your signal? Is just a it's a
break of structure? Simple M1 break?
>> Yeah, I find it's very easy to simplify
it into a very mechanical step-by-step.
Either it broke structure it didn't. I
try to take the discretion out of it
just because I'm trying to take so many
trades, it's easier if I follow a very
step-by-step plan for every account.
>> Cool. So we're consolidation, we're
going to break of structure, we're in
the right time window. The break break
of structure has happened now.
I guess you would cover the high. What's
the execution criteria?
>> As long as it closes below the structure
that it broke, I'm good with entering
and then the stop loss take profit are
static. So I don't I don't really
believe too much in putting stop loss
above previous high, take profit at a
specific previous low or whatever.
If you want a live account, it's
definitely something you should explore
more, but on prop firms it is infinitely
better to use static risk in terms of
like exactly a thousand, exactly 500.
>> Static risk makes total sense to me cuz
you're playing into the maths of the
prop firm model. What doesn't make sense
to me is a stop loss is there as an
invalidation. My idea it doesn't make
sense. So if I'm seeing consolidation
and a break back to the mean, okay, now
I have a thesis and that thesis is
probably no longer valid if price keeps
shooting up. So at some point I've got
to say, okay, this idea is aborted, but
if you're putting a static stop loss
based on the risk reward you want. That
stop loss might be placed in an odd
place where you could round it up and
say let's cover the high or yes, way
past the high I might as well cover the
high.
Does that not leave you a little bit
like okay, why is the stop loss here?
>> I don't I don't read too much into that.
I think just because the proper for
specific approach with the static stop
loss is like infinitely more powerful
than adjusting it by a few hundred
dollars to be in a specific point.
>> And I guess be with the background you
have you probably modeled out putting
stop losses at technical places where
you would protect it and it didn't work
out favorable.
>> No, no. I found infinitely better to
have a static stop loss.
>> How interesting. And with your TP is the
same thing you're not having profit
targets based on price action. It's just
a static level.
>> Exactly static. I think it's it's better
for prop firms just because of how the
rules have been structured.
>> So you have static risk per trade in a
dollar amount. You have static stop
loss. You have static
profit targets. And all you want of
them. What about the break even
protocols or trade management along the
way?
>> I never go break even which might be
interesting to hear unless there is a
new session opening. Like if I'm in a
trade at 6:00 p.m. and then Asian
session opens, I will go break even. Or
if we have news coming out then I will
go break even but like 95% of my trades
I'm not going to go break even.
I find it better to just let it play out
in the long run
because I'd rather be in the trade than
not in the trade even if it's pretty
much random from that point if it's
going back to my break even area.
>> I guess you modeled out
The the only reason someone would break
even is because I'm in a trade idea. I'm
moving towards my target and it has no
reason to come back. And I guess you
found that it can come back and still go
to my profit target more often than just
reverse on me.
>> Yeah, especially if you're mean
reverting.
>> Why is it more likely to reach a target
on a mean reversion as opposed to with
the trend?
>> If it goes back to break even, it's
mostly in my opinion market makers are
balancing inventory. So when there's a
very strict fast move on a reversion
like back to the opening price, it's
very common to see retracements because
it can't travel so far with only
one-sided orders.
>> Uh-huh.
Are you using level two, the order flow?
>> I've never, no.
>> Okay.
It's a very unique approach you have and
I'm struggling to resonate with it or
visualize it because it's so different
to everyone else that I've spoken to.
How did you come up with it?
>> Hmm.
Um,
I tried a lot of the things that you are
probably familiar with like order flow,
level two data, and specific profit
target stop losses all on live accounts.
I was able to have marginal success, but
I realized prop firms are a basically a
generational wealth builder at this time
in
in in our lives. So, I needed I knew I
needed a prop firm specific approach and
when I was modeling that specific level
two order flow, my specific trade
history and all that sort of stuff with
even specific take profit stop loss, I
found that my returns were not going to
be incredibly high. And the reason for
that is the prop firms don't want you to
make money. So, they obviously have to
structure their their rules in a way
where the most common trading
approaches, like on live accounts, is
not going to work. So, you have to do
something
not something against the norm if you
want to stand out and be extremely
profitable on prop firms.
>> It kind of makes sense in a weird way,
but it basically means you're not
concerned about alpha, you're not
concerned about concepts, strategies,
technicals, whatever. It's just pure
maths and you just need the only edge
you have is when to enter because
everything else is static. The break
even is static, the risk is static, the
profit and stop loss, everything is
static. It's just the moment you enter
and it and you just play the maths.
Which way is it going to go? Take profit
or stop loss.
>> Yeah.
>> Super unique. Um
would this apply on multiple asset
classes or is it only apply What What
are you trading specifically?
>> Futures for Nasdaq.
>> And and have you modeled this on other
areas?
>> Personally, no, just because Nasdaq is
the one that has at least the best
commissions and and the spread for my
trading approach, Um but it would
definitely work on prop firms if you had
the same strategy and that similar
approach where you're doing the static
risk and profit targets.
>> For the last 2 years, a proud sponsor of
the show is a top-ranked leading prop
firm, Alpha Capital. And for the years
that I've been working with them and the
thousands and thousands of viewers, you
guys, that have been working with them
through the discount codes of Titans of
Tomorrow, it's clear for me to see why
they are top-ranked prop firm in the
industry. They have also reached a
monumental milestone of a hundred
million dollars in payouts. And with the
multiple step plans and the multiple
package types they have, there's going
to be an option catered specifically for
what you're looking for. So, you can buy
an evaluation account catered to your
needs at the most competitive prices and
with our discount code TOT for Titans of
Tomorrow, you're able to get the most
unbeatable, unmatched prices in the
industry with a leading, trusted prop
firm. And with that being said, let's
get back to the episode. What would your
quant professors or peers who are now,
you know, PhDs or whatever the case may
be, working in an institutional
environment, what would they think of
you and and what you're up to?
>> I mean, I think they'd call me out.
They'd say, "Why aren't you trading on a
live account right now?" I think they'd
be a little bit confused about how prop
firms are so profitable if you approach
them in the right way. Um they would
probably feel like um their work on live
accounts and stuff for institutions is a
lot more meaningful just because they're
generating real value. Um but I
personally have found that prop firms
are basically zero risk if you're
approaching them correctly and it's like
an an incredibly profitable way to scale
your trading.
>> Looking back in the in the year and a
half, you've made Well, less than a year
and a half year and a half, you've made
1.5 million. So, you're running at about
100k a month consistently for a year and
a half. With the benefit of hindsight
and a year plus of progress, looking
back, could you have made more in in or
or did you optimize it and and fall in
the right path?
>> I followed the right path for about the
last 6 months before was
in terms of my prop firm approach, it
wasn't the best. Um my my risk
management then, even still, could have
been optimized. I feel like now it can't
really be optimized. I feel like I'm at
my limit. I'd also probably change the
way I approach the prop firms a little
bit differently. I might be more
aggressive on some, more conservative on
others, just because of how they how
they treat profitable traders.
>> Okay, I want to understand the the
foundation of the formula almost
to get to this comment, which is I could
have done risk differently or better.
What does that mean? Because you're
doing static or standard risk. So, what
is what is the variance? What are the
considerations to arrive to a decision?
>> With my specific strategy, I obviously
have a specific amount of points in my
favor if I'm trading a reversion back to
a specific price that I think is the
fair price. Now, obviously not all of
the time I can get there. If I have on
some accounts a 15-point profit target
that I have to take just for the prop
firm's specific approach. Um I would
definitely go at it from a a more
advanced approach now where I want to
have my profit target be exactly where I
think the fair price is. Plus, layer
that sort of live account approach in
with the static risk approach as well.
So, that would be like changing contract
size from like two to like 17 17 micros.
Like very small changes to increase your
return.
>> Which prop firms have you found the
greatest
opportunity, wealth-building opportunity
based on the rules and promises that
they have?
>> Topstep, Lucid, and TradiFi are
personally the prop firms that have paid
me out the most, and they have very good
prices as well. There's obviously
smaller firms out there that you could
work with as well that do pay you very
well.
And then, unfortunately, there is that
sector of prop firms that are not going
to pay you at all. So, it's just
important to avoid those.
>> How how do you flag that? How do you
know which ones are are sketchy? And
I guess you've also had your fair share
of denials.
>> I have. I had about 300,000 denied in
payouts. Which is it's quite a lot over
the over the last year and a half. Um
and there's no real really no arguing
with them. I try my best to post about
it online and and tell people stay away
from them.
Um
I guess I've sort of just found the
firms that I work with and it's just
those firms that I've been working with
for like 6 months. Every now and then a
new firm pops up like Lucid. Lucid
popped up on my feed I think in in
September of last year. I feel like I
was maybe one of the first people I
bought my first one September 8th, I
believe with Lucid um just to try them
out. So, what I do when I find a new
firm is I try it out one account only
and then if they pay me then I'll invest
more.
Just trying my best to look online,
YouTube, see if they have public
presence and then stay away from the
scams.
>> As as you said your professors and peers
would call you out. I was thinking what
would they say?
And I'm going to try and be in their
position and and challenge you which is
a goal of a trader is to find alpha
which basically means I need to have a
positive expectancy. So, day-to-day
varies doesn't matter but over time I
will make money and that's through data
mining or you know, finding pockets of
dislocation. That's the game.
>> Yep.
>> You're playing a completely different
game which seems more analogous to
gambling or a casino where you're just
playing the odds and knowing your
background in poker probably is where
this is birth where you're kind of not
concerned with real life alpha, you're
concerned with asymmetrical gain and
positive expectancy only in the arena
you're playing. So, is this kind of like
a casino gambling gamification model
inspired by that?
>> It could be, yeah. I think the trading
strategy as well has been developed by
my background but I'd ask you
most traders want alpha but most traders
want alpha because they want money. They
don't just want alpha, they don't just
want to beat the market. At least from
the people that I know they want to make
money. So, this is an extremely
profitable way to make money with little
to no risk because it's on prop firms.
So, that's personally why I do props.
But yes, I think there is a gamification
if you're optimally approaching the prop
firms. It is kind of hard to do that
yourself. You would definitely need
math, statistics and and modeling
background in order to do so. But, if
you're able to pair at least semi-solid
risk management with a decent strategy
like mean reversion, then you would have
very positive returns on prop firms.
>> I want to compare prop firms to the
casino because [clears throat] prop
firms have a baked-in edge. Uh they make
money when the gambler loses money. Uh
they just skew things in their favor.
And that's exactly what the house is,
the prop firm. And then you as the
player, uh the gambler, let's say, your
job is as a successful gambler would be,
you count the cards, you you play the
odds, you play the man, and you find
pockets of opportunity until the house
says, "Get out."
>> Yep.
>> What what is What is the approach that
you've taken from your poker background
into trading?
>> Well, I think the most important thing
that I learned from trading was
psychology, or from poker was
psychology. Um psychology is definitely
a very very strong part of poker. It
might be
analogous to trading psychology as in
like your poker skill is equal to your
trading strategy.
And then your poker psychology is
literally the exact same as your trading
psychology. So, I feel I feel like I
built a very very strong base in
psychology from poker. And I was able to
carry that over to trading where I feel
like I only tilted once in my entire
life trading and then never have since.
>> No way.
>> Yeah.
>> Why?
>> I think
obviously it's playing the odds most of
the time. Um I just know it's going to
work out in my favor cuz I've been doing
it for so long. And also I'm I just know
like how statistically bad it is to tilt
just based on like expected value of
these prop firm accounts. It's like I
understand exactly how much I'm risking
in terms of real dollars, and I know
that I'm going to trade on even if I
wanted to tilt, I would trade a
different account because the account is
worth a lot less.
>> I feel like every trader low-key knows
that. But, in the end, we're not robots,
we're human. And even if I know in the
heat of the moment, this probably not
the best decision. This is a FOMO or a
YOLO trade. The impulse feels so strong
that I can't help myself. Is where most
traders find themselves, especially in
their first year or two. How have you
been able to completely adhere to the
plan and and ignore such powerful
emotions that we all feel.
>> I think since I'm allowed to take 20
trades 20 plus trades per day with the
strategy, I feel like I'm always one and
done with the trade. I don't care if it
lost, I don't care if it won. I'm
already looking for the next
opportunity. I'm not hung up on on the
result of that trade. I'm not even hung
up on what it's doing in that trade cuz
I don't really go break even. I'm
automatically onto a new prop firm
looking at the exact same chart, but
just looking for another entry on a new
firm. So, I feel like I don't even get
distracted. I don't have to let the
trade play out. I'm just in this, and
then I'm over here on a separate task.
>> That is interesting because usually if
someone is taking one trade a week, then
if they place a trade on Monday and
there's a loss and they're pissed off,
they they've got five trading days left
to marinate on the idea, whereas you can
kind of get get that impulse or whatever
feeling out
in the next 30 minutes, well, which is
pretty interesting.
Um do you think out of all the trading
emotions that could exist from fear,
anger, greed, FOMO, all of all of these
powerful emotions that are common, do
you think confidence in your data trumps
all of it?
>> It should, but with human psychology, I
don't think it's fully possible for that
to play out.
Um personally, that's how it's been for
me. I think just because of my
background in quantitative finance and
poker, I think those combined have
created very very strong trading
psychology to the point where I know the
numbers, and then from poker, I know
myself. So, I know I'm not going to
enter any positions that would be
against my favor.
>> You were a university student when you
first bought your first few prop firm
accounts. So, your net worth was
relatively low as most students are. So,
then if you're floating P&L a couple
thousand, I remember when I was a
student, my rent was like $500 for the
month. So, if I was floating a grand,
that's a lot.
>> It would.
>> So, I'm
I'm more confused on you can be rigid,
you can have experience, you can have
your background you can refer back to,
but when when you're floating your net
worth
whatever the amount is, that's got to be
a loud emotion in your head. The
thoughts, the what ifs, so should I lock
it in early cuz I could do XYZ? How did
you navigate that in the in the first
month or or at least a beginning
moments?
>> I think the main thing in terms of like
holding positions to expiration is I
know it's optimal to do so, so I can
just sort of convince myself that I need
to do that.
Um but specifically on prop firms, if
I'm floating a thousand on a funded, I
don't really care if I lose that because
I only lose the two or three evaluations
I bought to get there, so I really spent
like $300 to be floating a thousand. So,
if I lose that thousand floating and
then my $500,000 stop loss, I'm
technically only down $300, so it
doesn't really seem like too much even
when I started with like $5,000. 300
doesn't seem like too much of that,
which um it definitely still is. Like
people should build a bankroll before
starting to trade, but um I still would
feel pretty comfortable just cuz the
risk and the downside is capped.
>> I'm very curious to know the process of
scaling because if we're sitting on 1.5
million, you have a one-to-four, it
means you start with multiple six
figures on evaluations. Now, the first
question that some of the comments will
have is where did you get this hundreds
of thousands of dollars from? But
probably is you reinvested payouts. So,
I want to I want to start off with like
let's let's build a journey.
>> Yep.
>> Because I'm sure throughout the phases
there's pivots you have to make, but I
guess it's from a hundred to a thousand,
from a thousand to ten, from ten to a
hundred, and from a hundred to a
million. Let's walk through these
chapters and the strategies you would
deploy to do it.
>> Yeah.
Um the first one, I was thankful to
start with about $20,000 just because
that's what I had made in poker and I
felt comfortable using that on trading
capital. Um but if someone were to start
with a hundred, I would probably
recommend them to not even start with a
hundred. I would recommend at least
start with a thousand just because you
want your risk of ruin to be 5% or less.
It's just a a pretty good approach for
trading in general. So, that would mean
you want to buy about like 20 accounts
or so um just so that the statistics
statistics will play out in your favor
over the course of 20 accounts.
>> How do you calculate the risk of ruin?
>> Basically,
when you hit the upside, which is the
payout, you have your pass rate, which
is like 25-30%, multiplied by your
chance of getting the payout. So, you
can sort of see like if I have 25%
chance to pass and then 25% chance to
get the payout, multiply those two
together, that's your that's like 6.25%
I think. So, then you
>> why you keep everything static?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Because your payout is always the same
amount then.
>> Yeah.
>> What is What is your payout amount?
>> Payouts, I try to go for max payout of
5,000 per payout.
>> Okay. And your likelihood of achieving
the payout is not your win rate.
>> Mhm.
>> What is that number? How do you How do
you How do you calculate that?
>> If I'm starting from eval, it's pass
rate multiplied by chance of reaching
$10,000 balance because I want to get to
a $10,000 balance on my account and then
take out 5,000, which would be the max.
>> What's the look back on uh you know,
chance of passing the eval? Is it the
last five most latest five or is all
evals you've done?
>> Personally, it's all of the evals that
I've done. Five is probably not enough.
I would recommend at least 50
>> Okay.
>> to have like an exact number, but you
can have a pretty good approximation for
like 20.
>> Okay. I'm following that formula. Now
that I've
put in my own numbers and I've got the
math and I know my risk of ruin is X.
How do I use that number?
>> You can use your your bankroll, like
determine exactly what bankroll size you
need to start trading, and then exactly
which prop firm accounts to buy because
you know if like you have a 5% chance of
getting a payout, which is probably on
the lower side, you have a 95% chance of
failing. And you can do like 0.95 to the
power of maybe like 20 if you're going
to buy 20 accounts, and then you'll know
my chance of getting zero payouts from
20 accounts is that number.
>> Huh.
>> And you want to know
>> you're just I mean, it's going to be
large numbers. It's going to be a lot of
accounts, but then in that worst-case
scenario, 5% chance of a payout,
you're always guaranteed to get a payout
and and reach the Yeah, so you're
literally just playing the maths. What
do the numbers look like for you?
>> Mhm. It is It is kind of hard to give an
exact number just cuz I'm on so many
firms and they all have different rules.
I try to pass about 30% of the
evaluations, and then payout rate I also
aim for it to be about 30%.
>> And would you say that's something
that's very dialed in
and it's taking time and effort to
master, or is this something a lot of
people could achieve?
>> It definitely takes a lot of time, um,
to create a strategy that works, to
create a, like, a life approach that
works to finding this many trades in a
day, uh, as well as statistics and
modeling your risk of ruin, modeling,
like, your bankroll, which prop firms
you should trade with.
Um, but I think it is possible if
someone is is really dialed in and
specifically taking this sort of
approach, it's possible.
>> I finally have a special offer to share
with all of you from the US or my
futures traders, which is over 20% of
the listeners of the show, and that is
Alpha Futures, a leading futures prop
firm that is working with Trade Evate
and Ninja Trader that are compliance
with CME regulations. With the largest
end-of-day balance drawdown in the
industry, and 90% profit splits, and
same-day payouts, [music] and with the
most competitive pricing in the industry
with accounts starting at just $79. On
top of that, just by being a viewer of
the show, you get up to 40% off all
evaluations. So, why not get started
with an evaluation right away? Trading
50,000, 100,000, and you already know
the power use the link in the
description or code TOT for the best
prices in the industry, plus the best
discounts in the industry.
To make this a home run offer if you are
a futures trader.
There's a concept that I play around
with in my head, which is called the
revolving door strategy, which is, let's
say I got a million dollars of capital
and I split up into 10 100K accounts.
Now, I could copy trade all my trades on
all 10 accounts. And then if I have a
good period, well, I got a lot of
payouts in one go. If I have a bad
period, I blow all of my capital in one.
So, therefore, I I I I mean, I used AI,
so I wonder how your calculator or the
math will get into that. But then I just
modeled it and said, uh, based on these
variables, KPIs of win rate, risk
reward, XYZ, uh, I just said, how often
should I space these out? Should or
should I trade them all independently?
And in my specific case, it was of these
10 accounts,
uh, trade
everything 1 week apart on a 4-week
cycle and a 1-week off.
Uh, and when you reach a payout, turn
that account offline until the next
cycle. And then when I modeled it out,
even I put in a losing equity curve
where the expectancy was minus you lose
30% across 100 trades. I modeled out
even that losing strategy, losing trader
made a 12K payout. I was like, okay, so
this is all just maths. Have you used AI
to do all of this?
>> No, I think I created the strategy a
while back when AI wasn't that
intelligent. I still talk to it a bit
about trading and and modeling and that
sort of stuff.
Um it does have some problems, obviously
it it can't account for psychology of of
the trader themselves, but it can lay
you out a very solid road map.
>> What about just the logistics side of
things? You know, all the different
rules and intricacies and even just
managing, okay, I've got these accounts,
this payout pending. Just for tracking
purposes, how are you doing it?
>> I just have an Excel spreadsheet. I've
been using it. Same Yeah, same
spreadsheet for like 16 months now. So
I've got it down. Whenever I buy an
eval, it just goes in the spreadsheet.
If I won it, if I lost it, that's also
noted, the date, the price, then the
funded account, if I got a payout, how
much was the payout, and I can just
track all of my statistics in one.
>> So I think I've been the in the lucky
and fortunate position I've spoken to
every trader on earth that's made a
million dollars in payouts at least. And
usually, in fact, all of them the story
has been from that million or whatever
multiple millions in payouts, there's
usually one huge payout of like 70% of
the total amount it was one moment, one
winning period. And you know, of course,
hats off to all of them, but then that
can also just be all stars aligned. But
I guess with your approach, there hasn't
been a huge blowup moment. It's it's
just base hits for a year and a half.
>> Exactly, yeah. I feel like there was a
golden age of Apex when Apex would pay
out a million dollars, two million
dollars to a trader. And then that's
obviously very profitable. I'm not sure
how Apex was existing as a company back
then, but yeah, some people hit huge
wins and they sort of die out because
they got like extremely lucky
with increased volatility. Like there
was the silver thing that happened with
Topstep. Topstep had to ban silver and
increase their prices just because of
how exploitable trading silver was. So,
definitely you can get lucky and get
huge payouts, but I find consistency is
a lot more important cuz I want to be
doing this long term. My biggest payout
has been 45,000 and then every other
payout from that then on is literally
5,000 or less.
>> Yes, it's crazy your biggest payout is
only 5% less than 5% of your total
earnings, which is totally uncommon for
any proper trader, I think.
What what is the key to the consistency?
Is it just it's in the math? There's
there's no hiding.
>> Yeah, it is.
Because you know math's going to play
out in your favor in the long run and
then just take as many trades as I
possibly can with a slight edge and then
it's going to pay me.
>> Is there any variables coming in
in terms of the model is shifting, the
prices are adjusting, the rules are
adjusting? How can you extrapolate past
performance to
you know, the next year and a half? Or
where do you see the timeline before it
starts to decay?
>> I can sort of extrapolate what I
currently have at a pretty good rate.
The only problem is the live accounts on
the prop firms. They're obviously
getting more and more strict because
they want to try their best to limit the
profitable traders.
So, that is sort of the only problem
that I've ever encountered with this
approach is just the live accounts that
they give and there's not really any way
to forecast how they'll change the
rules, but pricing is not really too big
of an issue.
>> Okay, I got a question. So,
I have a medical background. I did six
years of university and like yourself I
completed it. But during my degree is
when I came across trading, so by the
time I graduated, just like yourself, I
went all in.
My opportunity cost of what I would earn
as a dentist, which my classmates hourly
is between 5 and 15,000 dollars a month.
You start off at the five and you work
your way up and 50,000 dollars a month
is a nice plateau unless you do a
masters in XYZ. So, my opportunity cost
was basically if I'm not making six
figures from the path that I've chosen,
then I might as well have done that
minus a bit of fulfillment and XYZ.
Your opportunity cost with the
background you have is not the same. So,
I want to understand first of all,
what does your career lead to Uh, if you
had stayed on the traditional path that
you were on?
>> Yeah, most likely quant trading for a
very large institution. They pay very,
very well, even for entry-levels like
$300,000 a year. And then from there you
can obviously level up to 1 to 2 million
a year in a few years. And then maybe 10
years up to 5 to 10 million.
Um, so it was definitely a very
unconventional path for me to pivot away
from that.
>> Yeah, so the the uh, I'm a little bit
older than you. I've just hit 30. So, I
can imagine if you stayed on the path
you were on, by the time you're my age,
it wouldn't be weird that you earn a
multi seven figures, even eight figures
a year.
>> Right.
>> So, now the path that you're on, you've
had a phenomenal year.
How do you consider your opportunity
cost opportunity cost moving forward,
knowing that by the age of 30 or
mid-30s, you're going to be sitting on a
probably eight-figure net worth. Now
that is no longer your path, what what
are you going to do instead?
>> I would probably plan to open my own
hedge fund. Um, I never really
envisioned myself working long-term for
someone else, and that's sort of why I
pivoted away from the the traditional
9-to-5. Uh, which at a hedge fund could
be extremely stressful, and probably
even more hours than than a 9-to-5. Even
though it does pay well, I just couldn't
find myself working like that for that
many years in a row. I'd always want to
do stuff on my own time, and then get
paid exactly how well I do.
Um, but then in the future, yeah, I'd
like to open up my own business in terms
of a hedge fund.
>> Do do you think your age in the prop
firm environment, and just trading in
general,
is a help or hindrance?
>> In terms of prop firms, that's probably
helpful.
Um, I guess there's not really like a I
don't know if there's a specific age
group that does better at prop firm
trading in general, but I feel like
there's a a pretty common pipeline from
like gaming, at least from the people I
know, gaming into trading. So, lots of
people that I know that are really
profitable traders were very good
competitive gamers back in the like a
few years ago, and it's sort of like a a
pipeline that I've definitely seen.
>> The reason I mentioned this is because I
have three brothers. One of them is
19. He just turned 19. The other one is
28. So, a big age gap between them. Uh
they both started a business
independently. And I'm comparing the
two. And my youngest brother,
uh he's just got this delusional,
optimistic, uh never say no, go-get-a
mindset. And my other brother has just
been weathered by life. And therefore,
all the questions coming up like, "What
if?" And "Oh, but I've got these uh
burdens and responsibilities." And you
know, just the freedom and flexibility
that someone as a university student has
is unmatchable. And usually pairs nicely
towards taking an adventurous route. Uh
is this something that even comes to
your mind, or is just this is how it's
worked out?
>> Honestly, it's just how it's worked out,
but I definitely feel like people my age
and even younger can take a lot more
risks. Uh they have a lot more time to
build up a a stable sort of income, or
like a stable life. And you can take
more risks in terms of your investments.
You can take more risks in terms of your
career path. And I feel like that's sort
of where That's why I'm here now.
>> What have you done with all the payouts?
1.5 million in cash?
>> Yeah. Um honestly, most of it is
investing right now. So, I'm just
holding long-term investments.
Obviously, I don't know how long prop
firm trading is going to be a thing. So,
I want to pretty much save as much as I
can. I just upgraded my life in very
small aspects, like a new apartment and
then a nice computer setup. Like,
upgrading my life in terms of trading so
I can trade just a little bit better so
I can make more money. Um but honestly,
most of it is just going long-term
investments so that I can prepare for my
future.
>> I have to commend you on that because if
I was your age and had that much cash in
my account, most would do stupid things.
So, that's very responsible of you. Um
I'm curious now to know
with your successful run,
what what cuz I I I I assume you have
your eyes on the internet like most
traders do. What do you see that most
traders are doing wrong, especially in
your age demographic?
>> Honestly, I'd say copy trading. It's I
I'm personally, it might be a a pretty
strong opinion, but I think copy trading
is one of the worst things you can do
ever while trading.
>> Copy trading meaning taking 10 accounts
and placing all trades on 10. Yeah.
>> all at once.
>> Explain to me through maths why it
doesn't make sense.
>> So, the first reason obviously is
variance. If you're going to take 10
accounts at a time, you're going to risk
$1,000, that's $10,000. So, you would
need probably at least $2 million net
worth to do that, and I don't think
people that are risking $1,000 per
account have $2 million. Maybe on prop
firms you can reduce that $2 million
down to like 500 500k, but just variance
in general is a very very strong reason
why. And then
>> Just to jump in, how did you determine
your net worth should be 500k to 2
million?
>> and just do like 5%. It's a very quick
calculation.
>> Okay.
>> 100, 10k,
200k, and then even more, honestly. Like
sometimes you can multiply it by 10 just
for like an extremely safe 0.5% risk of
ruin.
I started with a 5% risk of ruin, now
it's 0.5%.
>> Wow, okay.
>> The copy trading very very bad for
variance, and then variance obviously
leads to tilt like 100%, even for
myself. If I was to copy, lose a bunch
of accounts, I would get really tilted.
But then the second reason is the risk
management. If you're copy trading, then
you're probably going to risk like 100
and go for 250
with 10 accounts, so that's minus 1,000
plus 2,500. Now, those very small risk
parameters are going to take absolutely
forever to pass an account. And if you
ever qualify for a payout, it's going to
be the smallest payout ever, or it's
going to take you like 50 days. So, why
not just do a minus 1,000 plus 2,500
trade, the exact same risk, but one
account at a time in order to pass it
like 10 times faster, and then get a 10
times larger payout for the exact same
risk and the exact same strategy?
>> What is your belief on
let's say I I'm shooting a ball into a
basketball net, and I get four in a row.
And let's say just my odds based on my
form and my skill and my everything,
it's a 50/50 chance that I that I get it
in. But now I've got four in a row.
How would you determine the odds of me
getting the next one in
factoring in just the probability that
my that my skill set has, but then also
factoring in form of like I'm on a I'm
on a hot streak versus overconfidence.
Obviously, I'm going to connect it back
to trading, but I'm just curious on your
on your broad thoughts on it.
>> I'd give you like a 53-55% chance to
make that next shot. Um just over the
course of your shooting history, it's
50%, so I'm obviously not going to go
below 50%, and then for the hot streak,
I would just add a little bit of
expected value in your chance of making
that. Um but trading, I feel like it's a
little bit different than that.
>> Exactly. I'll I'll what I'll ask the
opposite question, which is I got four I
missed four in a row. What's the odds
look like of the next shot going in?
>> Hm. Next one going in,
I would probably say 46-47.
So,
>> Okay.
>> as much as the the good side was
>> Slight variance. The reason I ask this
is because
let's say I've got a 50% win rate in the
markets. Now,
um
and I had a
seven-loss streak. And with a 50% win
rate, a seven-loss streak is pretty
abnormal.
>> Right.
>> The math wouldn't show that happens
often in a large sample size. So, if
that has happened, then usually the
decision is let me size down because my
psychology is taking a hit, and I'm
going through a rough patch, and my
strategy is gone, my alpha is decayed,
you know, there's all these doubts that
come in. So, usually people size down,
which I want to hear your thoughts on
because you have two outcomes. You
either size the same, and you go on tilt
because of the psychology burden of
seeing the large numbers, or you size
down, but then the time it takes to
recuperate is now extended because you
size down, and therefore being in the
hole for a longer duration is also
psychological weight. So, using math
with a touch of psychology, what is the
optimal decision to be making here? And
the reason I'm asking this is because I
came across a table, and I'm not sure if
you're familiar, which was basically the
chance of consecutive losses in a 100
trade sample size based on your win
rate. Have you seen this table?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah, I'm actually going to pull it up,
and we can probably throw it on screen,
too. Uh because I think it's just a cool
mental exercise. So, I'm going to I'll
pass it to over to you in a second, but
just to read it out a bit. Let's say
I've got a 60% win rate.
Uh the chances of me having
uh seven losses in a row out of out of
60% win rate is 17%. Okay. But then the
interesting one for me is if I've got a
40% win rate, the chance of me having
five losses in a row is 98%. It's going
to happen. So with this in mind and then
form and psychology in mind, how would
you navigate losses and a losing period
regarding the static risk philosophy
that you have?
>> I would keep my risk the exact same and
I would not change change the strategy.
The reason for that is if we're on prop
firms, obviously you can have a
different strategy because different
strategies have different max drawdown
periods just based on how they're built
and their risk to reward as well. So,
first of all, if your numbers play out
in your favor, there's no way you should
ever change your risk or your strategy
until you realize the numbers are not in
your favor. Um but I would keep it the
same just so that I would not have to
worry myself with is anything about me
and the strategy changing and I would
let the numbers play out.
>> Okay, the the the inference that I want
to get corrected or know if it's right
or wrong. Let's say I've got a
40% win rate and I'm sitting on my ninth
loss in a row. That's terrible. There's
a 35% chance of that. The chance that
that that that ninth loss turns into a
10th loss
is only 22%. So, how would I read that?
That I have a 40 or 45% win rate or I
have 80% win rate because the chance of
a next loss is only 22%.
>> Um hold on. Let me check that.
>> I I I want to I want to run it by you
because I didn't know what was
>> Correct. Um do do I look at the
independent uh basically does the string
of losses have a memory?
Um because I have a 40% win rate, so the
next trade should be a 40% win rate, but
the math is showing me nine to 10 is not
40. It's 80.
>> Right. You would use the multiplier
between those two. So, your chance
exponentially of getting nine versus 10
in a row is nine times 0.4.
>> Okay, I got that. So, we had to follow.
Okay.
>> Okay. So, each trade is memoryless,
which means if I was to lose nine in a
row
with a 40% win rate, my next chance for
a trade is still the same 40%.
To go from nine to 10, you would
essentially multiply that value at that
percentage at the ninth loss by 0.6,
which is your chance of losing. So, it's
essentially making the probability even
smaller. So, it's going to decrease your
percentage by whatever eight 18%.
But, the difference between those two
percentages
is just in terms of the whole, like how
likely it is out of a out of a whole,
not for the individual trade.
>> Yes. Yeah, I I I think the key part is
this is data based on a 100 trade sample
size, not a one trade sample size or
it's a it's a
that becomes a consideration. Very
interesting. Uh is there any Is there
any cool things uh because this is one
thing that has come across my feed over
the years. But, is there any cool things
that you've learned or tables or stats
or things that you've seen from your
quant background that would be cool for
traders to be aware of?
>> Mhm.
Mhm. It's a hard one.
>> No worries if nothing comes to mind, we
can we can skip over it. But, yeah, I'm
just thinking if there's any analogies,
there's any
uh you know, stories or there's any
quirky calculations that people be like,
"Oh, that's pretty weird. I didn't
expect that."
>> There probably are, but they're not
coming to top of mind right now.
>> Uh okay. Another thing that I I want to
throw at you then is
uh the idea of loss aversion. And and
just to put it simply is
uh people think if a flip of a coin um
if I win 100, lose 100, and I went to
strangers on the street that people take
that bet. But, most people would say no.
>> Yeah.
>> And if you skew the odds and say, "I
lose 100, but you, stranger on the
street, make 150." People still say no
cuz they're just thinking about the
losing 100. And when people start to say
yes, it's usually around uh I would give
them 250 as a stranger on the street if
they would uh uh
and if I lose, they pay me Sorry, if I
win, they pay me 100. So, needless to
say, the multiple or risk-reward uh is 1
to 2.5. Yeah. So, they uh willing to
forego a potential loss of 100 if they
could see a perceived upside of 250. So,
for me, the inference for that is loss
aversion means even if I recuperate my
accounts, I go through a losing period
and recuperate, so financially I'm break
even, mentally because of loss aversion,
I'm still in a deficit. How are you
accounting for this?
Because
I don't want to say you're just acting
like a robot, but there's got to be
something that I'm missing here on how
you can act so stoically and
robotically towards your system and
overcome all the normal emotions.
>> Yeah, I think the interesting thing for
people to hear is that those people on
the street that you go up to, it's
actually the correct decision for them
to say no, even if you're giving them
150 to your 100, even if you're giving
them good odds based on their bankroll.
It could be a very good decision for
them to say no. For example, if they
only had $100, then their potential
downside to losing that $100 is
basically nothing compared like it's or
I guess the upside is basically nothing
compared to the downside of losing
everything that they have. So, that's
sort of based on the Kelly criterion,
which is a mathematical way to solve for
the optimal bet size in a in a rigid
game where you have you like you know
your win rate and you know your your
risk reward. So, there must exist an
optimal bet size based on the reward
that you're getting paid out and how
much money you have to bet or play this
game. So, I did take that approach when
I started trading and basically it told
me exactly how many evals I could afford
with my specific bankroll. So, if I go
in with 5,000, then based on the return
that I expect to get, I would bet this
specific amount. Like buy this eval
because it cost 50, this one because it
cost 80, this one cost 100. Basically
just trying to give me a good enough
amount of accounts where my risk of ruin
is significantly low and I can realize
my expected value over time.
>> I'm glad you made mentioned the Kelly
criterion. Are you considering it in any
way? Because you're doing static risk
and usually the Kelly criterion
it tells you to do a lot higher risk
than most are comfortable with. So, I
wonder how you navigate that.
>> I used to use it a lot just because that
was how I would build up my scaling
program. Now I don't really need it just
because I sort of not not infinite
bankroll, but I'm not going to go broke
by buying eval just because it's
obviously a lot of evals that I could
buy and the edge is 100% going to play
out.
Basically get it's guaranteed in the
long run. If it's 215 eval, I'm spending
a million dollars. Like there's zero
chance of losing all of that. Um but
when you're just starting out, then the
risk might be a lot higher than people
think. You can obviously do quarter or
half Kelly where you're like a little
bit less aggressive than it would
recommend you and that's totally fine as
well just to build up a bankroll.
>> Very interesting. Uh I actually forgot
to ask as we were talking about the
phases of scaling. You started off with
20k. Um
did you go all in? You bought 20k all at
once and then trade them independently
or what
considering your risk of ruin? How did
you start off?
>> I started with 5,000. I felt like 5,000
and I'm going to trade the 50k accounts.
It's about $100 each so I can afford 50
and then my risk of ruin with like a 90%
that 90% chance of failing meaning no
payout to 0.9 to power 50 is like less
than 1% so I was very comfortable with
with $5,000 and I turned 5,000 into
17,000 trading the 50k accounts.
>> Okay, pause that for a sec. So the 5,000
with the math you have of expectancy to
pass the evaluation, the payout target
XYZ, all of those variables,
theoretically how much should you have
made?
>> How much should I have made for 5,000?
>> And did you with the 17,000 is that
ballpark where you needed to be or were
you under shooting over shooting?
>> I think it was the perfect actually.
It's like 3.3.4x so it's like exactly
what I was shooting for. I was shooting
for three shooting for three to four and
then it fell right in the middle. So
just exactly as expected.
>> Okay, now you're sitting on 17,000 in
payouts minus the 5,000 you're buying.
So yeah, you're walking away with just
over 10. With that 10 uh which is
basically whatever was got through the
first cycle, whatever the payout number
is in your case it was 12. What do you
do here? Do you go all in back again or
do you pay yourself a bit and go all in
with the rest?
>> There's two options um and it sort of
depends on how you would go all in.
There's a bunch of different ways you
could go all in. Personally, I was faced
with two decisions. The first one is I
turned five into 17 in about a month
trading on two prop firms.
Approach number one would be to do a 10k
to 34k approach with four prop firms.
So, double the firms, double the
investment, same amount of time. Second
approach is jump into the 150k accounts
with that $10,000 or whatever. And I'm
very grateful that I did the 50k
approach on four firms.
>> Why?
>> Because you need to treat prop firm
accounts like a portfolio if you're
looking to make incredibly large amounts
of money in the long run. So, treating
them like a portfolio means you have a
bunch of accounts at once. If I was to
trade five 150ks at a time, I'd
obviously be a lot more focused. I might
get better returns, but it's probably
not going to give me anywhere near
$100,000 a month. Five accounts probably
going to be like $5,000 a month.
>> You clearly a very intelligent person,
and I'm curious to know, do you think
intelligence plays a part in trading?
Or can this be a system that practically
anyone that would put in time and effort
could replicate?
>> I think intelligence in trading is is
half of it psychology. Obviously, I feel
like I know just in my in my own head
based on my experiences that it's just
so bad that I would never do that. So, I
think the smarter you are, the easier it
is to avoid that. But with trading
specifically, the smarter you are, the
easier it is to develop a strategy and
approach. But I feel like it is an
approach that many could follow if it
was explained step-by-step.
>> That that's very empowering for many to
hear, I'm sure. And where do you feel
like the threshold is before you start
to get diminishing returns in terms of
how much capital to hold? Because at
this point, you've got the bankroll to
buy all the prop firms that float
millions if you wanted to. What's the
sweet spot at this stage? So, people
will start to see what's the end goal or
what am I striving towards?
>> Right now, I'm trying to make about
$100,000 a month. It's a very obviously
very nice round number, but it's
interesting that it fell exactly on a
round number. Like I was at 75k for a
few months. I was wondering, can I ever
hit 100k in profit? Cuz I can hit 100k
in payouts, but can I ever hit 100k in
profit? And then eventually I did and
then I stuck with it.
>> So just to do the math, 100k in profit
means you need to have 50k out spend and
150k in payouts, roughly.
>> 50k in what?
>> In in sorry, out spend. In eval spend to
get 150k in payouts and then the net is
in your pocket, which is the 100k. Okay,
what does it take to do that?
>> It takes a lot. Personally, I'm trading
on 10 firms right now, all 150k accounts
trying to have all five funded active at
once on all of the firms. So it does
take about it does take a lot of spend.
That's a 3x from 50 to 150. I try to go
for a 4x so I can spend a little bit
less.
>> Okay, and what was the reason you were
struggling to break the 75 threshold?
What was it just a capital total capital
funded accounts that you had?
>> Yeah, honestly, I think I wasn't being
as aggressive as I should have been. I
was probably trading on seven firms at a
time. So honestly, you can just always
add more firms, which has more accounts,
but then with 15 more accounts, you got
to find like 15 more trades in a day or
start copy trading.
>> I've spoken to a variety of guests on
the show and a unanimous common
denominator between all of them is the
emphasis they put on data and actually
knowing the inner workings and the
insights of your edge and your
performance. That's why I'm proud to
bring a partner of the show, TradeZella,
the number one journaling, backtesting,
and all-in-one insights experience
created by traders for traders. What
TradeZella really gives you is deep
insights about your trading that would
ordinarily not be visible, whether it's
through understanding your trade types
and playbooks or even insights powered
by artificial intelligence through Zella
AI. Whether you trade forex, futures,
cryptos, the stock market, it all
seamlessly connects to TradeZella. So
there is no additional work. You've seen
me reference it dozens of times and all
of the benefits I've had in my trading
from the insights I found from my
TradeZella. So join myself and thousands
of other viewers of the show. You'll get
the best discount using the link in the
description or code TOT for Titans of
Tomorrow. You know what I what I really
like from this conversation is if
someone has this ambition of I want to
make 100k in payouts this year,
uh they'll be like, "Okay, I can do
that. Let me just start off and buy a
couple 50k accounts." But, if you run
the math, it will probably be very, very
unlikely with that amount of capital.
Or, the edge you would need would need
to be spectacular to achieve it. So, if
I want to make 100k, forget in a monthly
basis, but or even let's do it in your
case. If you want to make 100k next
month,
let's start off with what's the KPIs
starting off with the total funded
assets under management would be
required for that to be a reasonable
outcome.
>> Right. So, for me or you?
>> Hey.
>> In your case with the model that you
have.
>> Right. Uh we can go over like 50k spend,
150k in payouts because that's sort of
like
it's a less return, but you need like a
slightly worse strategy than mine. The
strategy basically just adds like a
little bit more return. Like from a 3x
return to like a 3.2, 3.3. So, that's
just why I I have that specifically.
But, if you have like
just a very decent strategy in general,
like not not the best, then 150k in
terms of payouts, I try to get 5k per
payout. So, I'll bring my account to
10k, take out half, back to 10k, take
out half, and just keep doing that. So,
150k divided by five is going to give
you 30 payouts.
Technically, like it's basically like
one payout a day for the month for
$5,000.
And it's definitely not the hardest
thing to do if you're running 40
accounts at a time. So, you could even
run 30 accounts. You would just have to
keep refreshing them if they lose. And
then just try to get one payout from
each account over the course of a month.
If it loses, if you lose your account,
buy another eval, pass it, reach 10k.
That sort of That sort of approach.
>> So, what's the math there? If I wanted
to run this, how much would I need in
total funding allocations?
>> [sighs]
>> Allocations, it would be 30 accounts at
150k. So, is that 4.5 million?
>> Oh, okay. So, it's a lot of It's a lot.
Um okay. Well, that that that's kind of
like uh ideal. 100k a month is a huge
huge milestone. What would the math look
like for 10k a month? Then it would just
be 450k in allocation running the same
maths.
>> Yeah, 10k is a lot a lot more
achievable.
Um I I personally modeled it when I
first started with 33% pass rate
and then a 33% chance to get a payout
for $2,000. That was very achievable for
me and my specific scaling ideas and
like my approach, my risk, and all that
sort of stuff. So, I do 0.33 * 0.33. So,
it's basically one out of nine evals
that I buy, I'm going to get $2,000 out
of it. Each eval costs me
I guess we'll say $100 on the upside.
So, I'm spending 900 and then I'm
withdrawing 2,000. So, with those
statistics, you can have an easy 2x
return. Plus, you still have $2,000 left
in your funded account because you only
took out half. From there, you could
either grow it back up to 4k to take the
max payout of 2k,
or you could just do some winning days
and then take out a thousand because you
had 2,000. So,
both of both approaches work. It's the
the same expected value for both
approaches just because of how recursion
works for funded account values.
So, both of them would be an option, but
I would aim to have one out of nine
evals
win.
I mean, sorry, one out of nine eval
purchases results in a payout for
$2,000. And then, you just need to do
that 10 times. At the absolute worst.
>> I think what we should do all what I
will do is I'm going to take the
transcript of this conversation because
you've basically given me the building
blocks to build a formula which then I
can create into AI dashboard and a tool
which is basically everyone can input
their own details of their chance of
possibility eval, what's the goal per
month they want to make. It will tell
them all the KPIs they need to achieve.
And then, it's just a reality check for
anyone. If my goal is this, does my
reality sit with it? And if not, yeah,
I've got to work on it. And then, people
can see directly, okay, I can do this.
Then, I just need to get to the funding.
Um
And I think I've got all the building
blocks, but if you can't if it comes to
your mind, what would be all the
variables because then some variables
people might not know their pass rate
for an eval. So, I can also give guide
rails of what is
exceptional, what is terrible, and and
what is
>> So, the first one is an evaluation cost.
>> Okay.
>> Just from whatever platform it is.
Evaluation pass rate.
>> Yes.
>> So, that's the whole eval phase. That's
all you need for the eval phase. Funded
phase gets a little bit more confusing.
The first variable that I like to
research is what I call average cost to
funding. And
>> So, you just said the first one of the
eval side, would time be a factor? How
long it takes to pass?
>> Right, it would. That's a good point.
>> So, it would be three here. And then on
the funding side, sorry.
>> The average cost to funded is a term I I
might have heard online or I might have
made it up, but if I buy three evals and
I pass one,
it cost me $300 to get to funded. So, I
have a $300 average cost to funded.
>> Okay, so yes, it's taking your pass
rates on evals times the average cost
to get your cost to funded on average.
Okay.
>> Now, for funded,
you want to know your chance of getting
a payout
and then how large that payout would be
to solve for your expected value.
>> And then once again, bringing in time
into this.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. All right, that's pretty That's a
pretty simple formula. And that that
would get us a rate of What What What
would be the end of this formula? What
What What What answer did we get?
>> We have the chance of a payout times how
large the payout is for the upside.
>> Okay, yes.
>> And then the downside is your average
cost to funded.
>> Okay.
All right, then that is comes a very
simple simple ratio. Uh
And then how would I determine what's
the effect or yeah, effective amount of
funding I need to achieve a payout rate
of 10K a month utilizing these two
numbers we've achieved?
>> First, let's look at the return. So, if
you if your average cost is 300, we'll
say 333 average cost to funded, and then
average payout expected value is a
thousand. So, three X return. Very very
achievable.
Um just look on the the upside. You need
to make about like 14,000
in payouts. And then with that 3x, take
a third of that.
>> Okay, that'll be your total cost. And
then from that, you just multiply and
say, "Okay, that's the funding you would
get." Okay, that's very easy. I think
I'm going to build that. We'll leave it
in the description cuz I think that's a
cool way for people to get a a dose of
reality.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and then lastly, I I I want to know
uh strategies-wise, a lot of people feel
like the holy grail in trading to get a
positive expectancy is in the system, is
in the strategy. And I think you've
completely real-wised through this
conversation for people to realize
sure it's that, but it's also way more
important to have the proper maths in
order. Right. But I want to know, are
you spending time dialing in your edge?
Or is it something that's kind of fixed
and you're just going to
keep playing the game? Or is it always
an advantage to try to find
opportunities and uh refinements in your
alpha itself?
>> There's technically always an
opportunity to make a strategy better
just through more data being collected.
Personally, I just do little changes
month to month based on sort of the
regime that the market's in. Obviously,
recently have a war, we have extremely
trendy all-time high markets. Sometimes
we have choppy markets. So, I'll change
the approach a little bit based on the
regime. But, if you're on a live
account, that's 100% the only thing you
should ever be doing is making your
strategy better. If you're on prop
firms, it's not really going to add too
much expectancy. It's probably the
difference between 3.2 and 3.3x return
on my investment. So, an extra 0.1% on
$150,000 is
is like 500.
>> JJ. You're very unique man. I don't want
to thank you for your time and sharing
unique insights and joining us on the
show today.
>> Mhm.
>> There we go.
>> you having me.
>> There we go. Boom.
>> Have a good one.
>> Nice episode, bro.